bien c'est bon comme ça et puis ce qui
était mis un coup de boule arrête c'est
difficile de rentrer chez toi ali avait
mis un coup de tête après un coup de
boule aussi pourquoi les connais non
alors il est question et moi mes excuses
comme ça mais tu es français toi relance
et moi pensons que français qu'est-ce
que tu joueras par en commentant
d'intimité mais date et lieu de
naissance 3 janvier 58 constantine ah si
loin bon et on poi poi l'avant 60
maintenant 68 non là le genre business a
rapporté et la taille à 9,74 à huawei et
il est tard quand même et habite la
ville dans le marais tes cheveux sans
quelques couleurs tes cheveux cheveux
bruns pas français et les yeux les yeux
marrons et les dents blanches les
miennes alouettes à l'ol je vois des
signes particuliers signe particulier
ses excellentes traitance yeux et tu as
des allergies voit la connerie humaine
mais en ce moment elle vole bas rhin
est-ce que 10 mois est ce que tu as des
maladies chroniques
[Musique]
ouais les bains douches à et quelques
petits grains de beauté par ci par là où
oui un sur la fesse droite a des
cicatrices
oui si tu remarques je parais la télé là
c'est un rien un petit la jab disent que
c'est la narine je crois je ne sais pas
si ça va intéresser téléspectateurs je
sais pas mais tu es droitier ou gaucher
je suis droitier bon nous allons encore
rentré dans une question difficile
opposés mais j'espère tu vas me répond
vraiment avec avec franchise
est ce que parce que beaucoup de gens
qui se posent des questions tu sais
comment cette connu maintenant et qu'est
ce qu'il fait est ce que tu fume des
pétards
voilà je lâche le bon alors
[Musique]
une ne bat à je me jette à l'eau
qu'est-ce que tu baisses sans capote un
jeu mais plus de capotes parce que je ne
baisse plus parle de ça est ce que tu es
marié
oui c'est pour ça que je maris ou
concubins à vous je suis con cuba
fréquence koïta ça veut dire que la
fréquence c'est à dire qu est ce que tu
as dit j'ai rien compris
combien de fois tu as ça ça regarde
personne c'est regarde que moi la date
du premier rapport sexuel mais vraiment
précis et 18 ans et c'est une très très
belle aventure
c'était dans une chambre près de paris
avec une jeune fille qui était très très
belle et je rentre dans l'intimité
oui pour sortir desquelles j'ai fait
croire qu'il était le fils d'henri
salvador alors parce que je crois que tu
te faisait passer pour le fils de canal
à willer matin j'ai tout fait parce que
nous a tous fait un gros menteur menteur
mon âge aviation qui était le fils
d'henri salvador et la gym traders mais
l'assuré est ce que tu as déjà eu
recours à des prostituées
absolument pas avec put bon tu sais en
ce moment les maladies et puis moi je
paye pas est-ce que tu as eu des
expériences homosexuelles mais quand
j'étais petite touche pipi bon touche
pipi hausse à 3.5 et kate en 1 40 d'art
ouais ouais j'ai eu des expériences
homosexuelles mais me faire à talbot non
jeûneurs est ce que tu as déjà baiser
par gardant un jeu à la télé avoue
franchement dit le désir dans un jeu non
j'étais toujours la télé tu rigoles je
peux pas faire l'amour en en d'avoir la
télévision on peut choisir
retourné vaquer de linars d'études
abonnez vous je m'étais un peu ce bleu